Now in this previous question,
the ratio is 1 to 2.
Sometimes you'll see such
a ratio written as 1 colon 2.
And this just means the exact
same thing is 1 over 2.
I actually prefer 1 over 2, because
really what we're doing is division, but
you will see this a lot and I don't
want you to be confused when you do.
So, for example with 3 out of 5
dentists, this ratio is the same as 3:5,
and you would read that as 3 out of 5,
or 3 to 5.
And so, thinking of the examples
we've gone over so far.
3 out of 5 dentists, 8 out of 10 cats,
200 out of 500 graduates,
and 2 to 9 being the ratio of
color printers to total printers,
we could have written any of
these using our colon notation.
3:5, 8:10, 200:500, 2:9.
Of course, we should still simplify
when we can, but the idea is the same.
Let's do a little bit of practice.
As I'm filming this,
it's near tax day in the United States.
So 3 out of 36 forms
were filed incorrectly.
I want to know,
what's the ratio in this sentence?
Enter your answer in this box, and
this time, try using colon notation.